remettre dans l'emploi le gouvernement
dans un premier temps n'avait pas bien
compris notre dispositif et là je pense
qu'on est arrivé à à lui faire bien
comprendre les mesures de fraude on est
les seuls à avoir proposé près de 200
millions d'euros quand même d'économies
elles sont des sommets gravées dans le
texte l'usure professionnelle avec cette
capacité à faire partir les gens dès 60
ans lorsqu'ils sont usés lorsqu'ils sont
en incapacité parce que si on le fait
pas si on le fait pas partie ils vont
toucher des pensions d'invalidité ou
alors ils seront en arrêt de travail
donc vous êtes vous êtes heureux du
compromis qui a été trouvé entre on va
dire l'amendement Pradier comme on
l'appelait sur les carrières longues
l'amendement Marleix alors c'est c'est
non c'est l'amendement Marley ce qu'on a
retenu on ne souhaitait pas avoir
l'amendement Pradier parce que ça ça
bouleversait à la fois les règles de
notre système mais surtout sa
bouleversait l'équilibre financier il y
avait plus de recul en fait
notre système c'est deux critères c'est
à la fois une durée de cotisation mais
aussi c'est une borne et cette borne là
elle est faite pour ne pas créer des
retraités pauvres parce qu'il y a des
mécanismes de surco c'est pour ça qu'on
n'était pas favorables mais on a fait
aussi nous-mêmes des compromis et je
sais que mon collègue Olivier Marleix
pour lui c'était une mesure importante
notamment vous n'étiez pas d'accord sur
cet amendement Marley tu ne l'avez pas
voté le gouvernement n'y était pas
favorable non plus vous avez changé un
peu on a fait on avait fait à mi-chemin
si j'ose dire le travail puisqu'on avait
adopté la quatrième borne d'âge entre 20
et 21 ans ce qu'on peut dire c'est dans
les années à venir après 2030 un
Français sur quatre pratiquement partira
dans le cas de ces carrières longues
donc encore une fois je le dis à ceux et
celles qui peut-être ont toujours des
doutes je sais que demander des efforts
aux Français c'est difficile un si on
fait rien on fait exploser le système
des retraites par répartition les riches
sentiront et capitalise c'est les
pauvres qui perdront qui trinqueront
deuxième chose en 2030 nous serons de
tous les pays européens mais alors là de
très très loin
le pays d'Europe où on partira le plus
tôt en retraite où on aura notamment le
régime de carrière l'angle plus
avantageux et aussi un des très très
bons régimes pour l'usure
professionnelle et pour la pénibilité ça
veut dire qu'il faudra une autre forme
non ça veut dire que déjà 2030 on a
cette réforme elle est très équilibrée
et très franchement et vous savez j'ai
souvent critiqué le gouvernement et
Emmanuel Macron à ce micro je pense
qu'on aboutit à une réforme qui comporte
des avancées notamment sociales
notamment pour l'usure professionnelle
et aussi par exemple pour les
travailleurs handicapés bien sûr donc ça
il faut en prendre acte maintenant on
sait parfaitement que on va avoir un
choc démographique énorme puisque c'est
plus le baby-boom c'est le papy-boom
qu'on va multiplier les départs en
retraite à l'avenir et que le régime par
répartition je pense pour ma part dans
l'avenir devrait être complété par un
régime solidaire pour que on embarque
tout le monde et notamment les plus
modestes par capitalisation si ce
système était
équilibré en tout cas le compromis a été
trouvé à quoi sert la clause de revoyons
en 2027 ça c'était les députés qui
tenaient beaucoup pour faire un point
pour savoir si dans les dispositifs ils
pouvaient pas être par exemple ajouter
tel ou telle mesure c'est beaucoup plus
une mesure conservatoire une mesure
précaution c'est pas une manière
d'anticiper un futur débat pour la
présidentielle non je vais vous dire
mais vous avez raison que la comment
dirais-je la vraie clause de revoyure
c'est l'élection présidentielle bien
évidemment mais les députés étaient
attachés à ce point-là et moi j'ai
essayé aussi de dire à René Paul Savary
je veux saluer René Paul Catherine de
roche et Isabelle Doisneau les
rapporteurs la prison de commission ils
ont fait un boulot fantastique à tel
point que René Paul accompagnait Olivier
Marleix pour à la réunion de groupe des
députés ça se fait pas souvent quand
même pour expliquer le dispositif tel
qu'il avait été conçu il y avait
vraiment un énorme et très beau travail
est-ce que l'équilibre financier il est
assuré maintenant que le compromis alors
justement dans ce compromis là moi
j'avais donné comme feuille de route
notamment à René Paul Savary de veiller
précisément à obtenir un équilibre
puisque le point de départ de la réforme
ce sont des déficits le point d'arrivée
de la réforme ça pouvait pas être à
nouveau des déficits et on a dû
abandonner par exemple des retraites
progressives à partir de 60 ans pour la
repousser à 62 ans parce que c'était
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
et on ne pouvait pas tout obtenir
et ça compense notamment les carrières
langues moi je regrette que le
gouvernement est écarté d'un revers de
main m'a proposition sur l'angine
spéciaux parce que alors là c'était
entre 1 et 2 milliards
on sait que au sein de l'Union centriste
pas non plus une majorité c'est
paradoxal parce que c'est amendement on
le vote tous les ans avec les amis
centrist et on le voit toute une forme
et juste pour comprendre bien vous
voulez accélérer la suppression des
régimes en 2040 en 2015
c'était pas 2040 c'était 2030 c'était
une version campus est-ce que vous allez
est-ce que vous allez retravailler sur
cette question est-ce que vous allez
redéposer à un moment peut-être un
amendement lors du prochain projet de
loi de la sécurité sociale on va
travailler on va travailler je pense que
on parlait aussi de l'avenir moi je
tiens vraiment au régime par répartition
je tiens au régime par répartition tout
simplement parce que c'est le socle de
notre pacte social et au-delà du niveau
des retraites au-delà de ce que les
jeunes doivent pouvoir compter comme
vrai retraite demain ce qui se joue
c'est un lien intergénérationnel et vous
savez dans une France qui est
archipelisée qui est morcelée le régime
par répartition se lient il concrétise
immatérialise ce fait là que nous sommes
dépendants des uns des autres je pense
que dans une société où l'individualisme
de masse fait des ravages il faut
impérativement le garder sans doute
faudra-t-il le compléter on l'a
d'ailleurs avec les régimes
complémentaires à point vous savez qu'un
régime complémentaire comme l'agirco
c'est un régime à point en réalité qui
complète on a déjà une fusée à deux ét
il faudra voir si à l'avenir on ajoute
pas un étage sur une capitalisation qui
permettrait un à tous d'avoir une
meilleure prospérité de meilleures
retraites y compris pour les plus
modestes à condition que ce soit un
régime solidaire je le dis bien et je le
répète et qui nous permettrait d'avoir
des fonds souverains pour développer
notre industrie pour développer les
investissements que nous avons à faire
en matière de transition écologique une
réflexion sur une introduction d'une
part de capitalisation ça a été retiré
de la cantine
non c'est pas cela du tout c'est que les
députés avaient voté un rapport sur un
régime universel à points et nous on
avait voté un rapport donc c'est ce que
j'avais indiqué avec René Paul et
Catherine roche on s'en était expliqué
on s'est dit ou bien il y a pas de
rapport du tout ou bien c'est notre
rapport mais qu'est-ce que ça voulait
dire maintenir deux rapports d'un par
capitalisation et l'autre régime
universel a point si vous voulez rien
dire donc chacun a fait un pas vers
l'autre et on a éliminé les rapports ce
qui va pas nous empêcher de travailler
il y aura une mission entre la
commission des finances et le rapporteur
général chez nous Jean-François Husson
et Catherine de Roche La Mecque
notamment présidé par René Paul Savary
une mission pour envisager l'avenir long
[Musique]
pour assurer l'avenir dans l'état actuel
de du groupe notamment du groupe les
républicains l'assemblée on va en parler
qu'est-ce que vous feriez si vous étiez
à la place d'Emmanuel Macron ce matin je
ne suis pas à sa place d'une part je ne
suis pas à sa place aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement périlleux et il me semble
que les comptages ne perdent pas de
distinguer une marge suffisante pour
assurer une victoire du texte à
l'Assemblée nationale alors est-ce que
les résultats
CMP on a des bons résultats ou les
députés ont obtenu aussi un cercle de
choses peut en réalité faire basculer
des voix contre ou des voix qui
s'abstenaient dans des votes positifs
c'est possible mais ça je peux pas le
dire moi je suis président d'un groupe
au Sénat et Olivier Marleix serait mieux
à même que moi de vous le dire mais
encore une fois je pense que très
franchement c'est du kit ou double il
faut pas que il faut pas que la roulette
russe transforme en roulette belge comme
je le disais la roulette belge la
roulette russe c'est voilà dans un bar
c'est le barillet il y a il a six balles
sur 6 donc ça ressemble ça ressemble à
du suicide on va pdlr mais hier soir
Emmanuel Macron a réuni à l'Élysée
Elisabeth borne et les ministres
concernés il fait planer la menace d'une
dissolution en cas de vote perdu comme
dites-vous c'est le jeu éternel c'est un
jeu qui consiste à faire pression à la
fois sur sa majorité pour que des
barbara Pompili et quelques autres votre
bien la réforme mais que c'est aussi un
gourdin brandit vis-à-vis de l'air en
disant attendez faites très très
attention si vous allez trop loin vous
pouvez vous retrouver de vous électeurs
et je pense que la perspective serait
inquiétante pour nous simplement je
crois pas un seul instant que il fera
une dissolution actuellement parce que
sans doute on pourrait perdre beaucoup
mais je pense que le groupe Renaissance
perdrait évidemment aussi voilà mais
vous dites attention s'il y a une
dissolution vous allez perdre je dis
surtout à certains qui ont voulu qui ont
déclaré
excusez-moi du peu qui pourrait
s'associer à des voix de la nupesse de
LFI d'extrême gauche ou du rassemblement
national pour voter une motion de
censure et je vais vous dire cela s'il
le faisait il se comporterait comme les
idiots utiles cela il se Mélenchon ou de
marine pourrait être exclu parce que en
effet Olivier Marleix ou je crois que
Jacky l'un des deux adultes déclaré mais
ce serait les idiots utiles Olivier
Marley ça dit s'il vote avec le groupe
avec les écologistes
ce serait les idiots utiles de Mélenchon
ou de Le Pen voilà c'est tout
le gouvernement on dit aussi que si le
groupe LR n'est pas en capacité de voter
ce projet de réforme en fait il
prouverait qu'il n'est plus un parti de
gouvernement vous êtes d'accord ah c'est
inquiétant la séquence a été inquiétante
pour nous bien sûr bien sûr puisque il y
a encore quelques mois on a fait
campagne sur un report de l'âge à 65 ans
et une fois de plus on est à 64 ans avec
énormément de mesures d'accompagnement y
compris la réforme que nous avons assumé
avec François Fillon Nicolas Sarkozy en
2010 qui repoussait de deux ans déjà
l'âge de départ l'âge légal de départ
avait comporté moins de mesures
d'accompagnement donc moi je suis
stupéfait que on puisse changer de ligne
d'un jour à l'autre je crois que la
politique et c'est pour ça que elle est
a perdu du temps de voir des millions de
voix ou courte ces dernières années je
pense que notre ligne n'est plus lisible
on n'est plus audible mais est-ce que
justement vous ne vous ne
m'accusez pas certains de faire preuve
de trop de discrétion Laurent wauquin
c'est pas vraiment exprimé on dit
d'ailleurs que une défend pas du tout le
texte en privé Xavier Bertrand
clairement ses positionné contre cette
réforme regretter ces positionnements
j'ai bien vu que les présidentielles
s'invitaient à la table de la réforme
déjà vous savez j'ai fait campagne on
s'était croisé dans votre Nord
bien-aimé
tout à fait et très franchement
j'avais dit attention en faisant en
sorte que on réfléchisse au présidentiel
le moment voulu mais pas avant les
européennes il faut se refonder il faut
vraiment dans un monde qui bouge
énormément dans une société française
qui qui a beaucoup beaucoup bougé elle
aussi il faut qu'on réinvente notre
logiciel doctrinal idéologique politique
et je vois bien que on est toujours dans
cette guerre des égouts quand même c'est
fragilisticiens
le peu de goût pour les idées voilà et
le trop de goût pour le chef le trop de
goût pour l'individu mais là c'est ça
dans la tête d'Aurélien Pradier pour
vous c'est ça c'est une question d'ego
une question qui est déjà la
présidentielle très franchement j'ai
renoncé à comprendre donc parler à
anthropologue ou à des gens qui sont
plus finalistes que j'ai renoncé j'ai
renoncé à essayer de comprendre quoi que
ce soit non simplement ce que je veux
dire c'est que la politique 1 se doit
être une ligne claire et quand la
politique c'est des têtes à queue en
permanence c'est plus compréhensible et
surtout je pense que la politique ça ne
peut pas être le tout-à-l'égo comme je
l'avais écrit dans un livre qui
s'appelle refondation tu imagines que
vous avez parlé depuis l'accord en CMP à
Olivier Marlet ça a Éric Ciotti est-ce
que vous savez à peu près maintenant ce
matin alors on se parle combien de
députés à l'air votre oncle cette
réforme je vous dirai pas de chiffres
j'ai eu tard hier soir Éric Ciotti voilà
en tout cas les chiffres qu'il m'a donné
hier soir mais
comment dirais-je les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire n'avait pas
encore suffisamment percollé peut-être
les chiffres qu'il m'a donné hier
comment dirais je me laisse penser que
un vote aujourd'hui en se passant du
49-3 est un vote très très très risqué
ça veut dire que personne n'a basculé ou
très peu de députés ont basculé malgré
l'accord en CMP c'était sans doute trop
tôt puisque c'était juste après la CMP
mais si ce chiffre entière ou plus
peu importe mais on est autour on est
autour de 30 pour rentrer 35 et une
vingtaine de
contre c'est ça et une vingtaine contre
donc oui voilà donc pour l'instant les
chiffres d'hier soir n'ont pas vraiment
bougé mais peut-être que dans la nuit ce
matin à force d'y réfléchir il peut y
avoir quelques voix
Eric Ciotti est-ce que c'est il a
suffisamment d'autorité sur le groupe
les républicains très franchement on
s'est opposé l'un à l'autre on a fait
campagne l'un contre l'autre si j'ose
dire c'était on était des les deux
principaux candidats il y a quelques
mois franchement moi j'ai pas une
critique à émettre sur le comportement
des riz qui nous a il a donné une ligne
assez courageux ce qui était aussi la
mienne on avait fait campagne d'ailleurs
sur cette ligne là pendant les derniers
mois de l'année pour LR mais non
franchement il a fait le job il a fait
il a bien fait il a mouillé la chemise
et très franchement je j'aurais aimé que
d'autres Lamouille aussi évidemment
autant que lui comme Laurent Voulzy non
mais mais toutes les grandes voix toutes
les grandes voix il y a pas que leur en
Vautier il y a pas que leur invoqué moi
je je comprends il a théorisé
une mise à l'écart il a théorisé sa
propre mise à l'écart du débat national
donc je comprends qu'il va y aller
jusqu'au bout et que rien ne trouble
cette stratégie mais mais sur des
questions aussi importantes pour
l'avenir du pays encore une fois la
retraite par répartition c'est les
retraites de demain notamment des jeunes
c'est aussi plus d'activités plus de
travail dans la machine économique parce
qu'on aura un meilleur taux d'emploi
notamment pour les plus âgés et puis
c'est le modèle social c'est ce qui nous
lie c'est ce que nous sommes c'est un
bien commun c'est ni de droite ni de
gauche je rappelle que la sécurité
sociale le régime par répartition il est
inventé à la fois par la droite et la
gauche et notamment tous les gaullistes
devraient sans féliciter un dernier mot
puisque vous avez dit ce qui voterait
une notion de censure devront être
excluées ce qui ne voterait pas ce texte
pour vous doivent être exclus un député
un député un sénateur heureusement il y
a une liberté et moi je suis attaché à
cette liberté
vraiment sur chaque texte et alors là en
plus vous savez un mot quand même nous
qui sommes dans l'opposition moi qui
suis des principaux faire de lance si
j'ose dire contre la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron pas depuis hier mais
vraiment depuis l'origine de son premier
quinquennat c'est compliqué quand on est
dans l'opposition de porter une réforme
aussi difficile parce qu'elle demande
des efforts vous voyez il faut aimer son
pays il faut avoir des convictions faut
se dire que on est plus attaché à
l'intérêt général que à son propre
intérêt c'est ça donc je comprends
parfois il y a une petite évaporation
des voies dans l'abstention très peu
finalement de contre au Sénat très très
peu précisément sur un groupe de 145
l'Inter syndical Demande à l'ensemble
des députés de ne pas voter cette loi
qu'en dites-vous
que vous allez pas voir Monsieur
Martinez débarquer sur votre studio les
moustaches relevés pour dire attendez
voter la loi ah non mais ce serait tout
le monde serait vous-même sous la table
voilà c'est pas surprenant mais est-ce
que vous estimez que si la loi est
adoptée alors que ce soit par le vote ou
pas un 49-3 il serait
normal que les manifestations s'arrêtent
écoutez moi ce que j'observe c'est que
et vous l'avez vu vous-même vous êtes
des observateurs avisés hier il y a eu
moins de grévistes et beaucoup moins de
manifestants donc on voit bien que le
mouvement social s'effiloche mais il
peut se radicaliser alors il peut se
radicaliser bien sûr il y a des coupures
d'électricité bien sûr il y a eu un
certain nombre de menées un peu partout
en France mais mais ça c'est le fait de
minorité et je parie sur le fait que les
grands syndicats réformistes une fois
que la loi aura acquis la légitimité du
vote parlementaire oui il pense qu'ils
n'auront la légitimité du vote
parlementaire est-ce que vous ne
craignez pas que finalement l'usage du
49-3 mais ne devienne l'allumette du feu
social
l'usage du 49-3 s'est un usage
constitutionnel et démocratique
n'oubliez jamais que en face du 49-3 les
députés ne sont pas démunis ils peuvent
déposer une notion de censure et
renverser le gouvernement c'est un jeu
là encore démocratique le gouvernement
engage sa responsabilité sur un texte à
travers le 49-3 mais les oppositions
peuvent se coaliser pour faire chuter le
gouvernement c'est encore une fois une
balance prévue par notre Constitution
donc c'est parfaitement démocratique
vous avez parlé des coupures
d'électricité vous en avez été vous-même
victime l'électricité a été coupée à
votre domicile coupure revendiquer par
la CGT énergie de Vendée votre
département vous avez porté plainte oui
oui bien sûr j'ai porté plainte je
signale d'ailleurs à la CGT qu'il y a un
article du code pénal qui est un article
un peu rude mais je le redis 440 433-3
qui dispose que ben voilà il y a des
lourdes qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 10 ans
de prison 150000 euros d'amende quand on
veut faire pression notamment sur un élu
pour que ils puissent par intimidation
par chantage changer son vote ou
accomplir un acte dans le cadre de son
mandat on est on est dedans
bon ma petite personne est un détail
j'observe quand même que il y a eu des
EHPAD qui ont été coupés des des
cliniques il y a eu des écoles etc et
surtout de la part de la CGT énergie des
choses qui ont ils ont vraiment
absolument inacceptables c'est que on a
réduit la production d'électricité en
France on a dû l'équivalent de plus de 5
réacteurs nucléaires on a dû importer
beaucoup beaucoup d'électricité avec
tout ce que ça pu coûter ce sont des
gens qui sont intéressables d'autant
plus je reviens à mes régimes spéciaux
qu'il bénéficie de régime spéciaux et
que eux seront les seuls Français les
seuls qui ne seront pas impactés par
cette réforme les seuls les privés le
seront personnel qui travaille dans le
privé dans la fonction publique aussi
mais eux pas de problème ils ne le
seront pas est-ce que les Français
trouvent ça normal bien sûr que non ça
n'est pas normal ils peuvent venir me
couper le courant une fois de plus il
m'empêcheront pas de dire ce que j'ai à
dire hier soir sur LCI Philippe mart à
justifier cette coupure à votre domicile
il a dit je le cite Bruno Retailleau a
été mis en sobriété énergétique pour
qu'il se mette à la place des millions
de Français qui n'ont pas les moyens de
payer de l'électricité c'est juste pour
le mettre au niveau du peuple que lui
répondez-vous je ne connais pas la vie
de Monsieur Martinez
la maison dont ils ont coupé
l'électricité c'est la maison que mon
grand-père fut une ferme que le
grand-père avait acheté avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale et moi je vis
depuis toujours dans un village de 1500
habitants j'ai créé une école de musique
j'ai comment dirais-je animé un foyer de
jeun je vis moi les gens moi j'ai pas
demandé moi mais mes camarades mes
copains c'est avec eux que j'ai
usé mes fonds de culottes il y a bien
longtemps et ils occupent pas ils
occupent pas des grandes responsabilités
c'est là que je me ressource j'y trouve
une relation absolue très très vraie on
a ils ont créé un super festival je
voudrais faire la publicité pour le
festival de poupée voilà on a reçu Joker
on a reçu les plus grands bref c'est ça
c'est saint-malo-dubois c'est 1000
bénévoles vous voyez moi vous n'avez pas
de de
racines sont mes racines et Monsieur
Martinez il n'a pas de son à donner de
peuple justement voilà moi je voilà je
me sens bien parmi les miens voilà c'est
mes racines c'est tout sont souvent
agriculteurs artisans ou ouvrier mais ce
sont mes vrais amis
sur l'énergie puisque la réforme portée
par le gouvernement qui a pour but de
fondre l'Institut expert en France de la
sûreté nucléaire au sein de l'Autorité
de sûreté nucléaire a été rejeté en
première lecture par l'Assemblée
nationale à deux ou après malgré
l'apport des voies du rassemblement
national c'était une bonne chose vous
vous l'auriez vous vous l'auriez voté
cette fusion des deux instances alors
moi j'y suis plutôt favorable mais
j'observe que le gouvernement s'est pris
les pieds dans le tapis d'une façon
lamentable absolument lamentable on a
nous voté un texte et on n'a pas vu
d'arriver cette fusion ça n'est pas
normal une fusion on le prépare on fait
une étude d'impact on essaie de
préfigurer on peut se passer
c'est que elle n'est pas favorable sur
le fond moi sur le fond j'ai su
favorable j'observe simplement que je
gouvernement n'a pas pris les
précautions nécessaires on ne fait pas
lorsqu'il s'agit de la sûreté nucléaire
française on y va pas dans la
précipitation voilà c'est pas du travail
ça n'est pas professionnel tout
simplement et et très peu démocratique
dans la mesure où encore une fois à la
première lecture au Sénat sur ce texte
nucléaire on n'a pas eu l'occasion de
traiter ce point-là donc il faut soit
aujourd'hui le Gouvernement arrête la
procédure accélérée et donc on continue
et il y aura des navettes dans chaque
chambre pour pouvoir ajuster le tir ou
alors le gouvernement suspend cet
amendement là prend des précautions fait
une étude d'impact une étude de
préfiguration et nous propose un texte
un autre vecteur légitime
on appelle au Sénat lors d'une seconde
lecture si on a nous un certain nombre
de précautions je préconise moi un autre
vecteur par exemple on peut parfaitement
le voter parce que sur le fond encore
une fois en tout cas à titre personnel
j'y suis mais pas lors de la seconde
lecture de ce texte c'est ce que vous
dites non il faut un autre je ne dis pas
ça je pense qu'il aurait été mieux
d'avoir un texte différent à partir du
moment où ils ont loupé le coche de ce
premier texte si il y a une lecture par
exemple de lecture s'ils abandonnent la
procédure accélérée on peut toujours le
voir je non non je ne ferme pas la porte
je ne ferme pas la porte c'est pas la
meilleure des solutions mais c'est une
solution qu'on peut quand même étudier
ici au Sénat et je sais que j'ai relâché
été intervenu pour justement l'abandon
de cette procédure accélérée merci
beaucoup c'est moi qui va arrêter notre
invité merci Julien la Une de La Voix du
Nord je la regarde la rue mobilisée
attend le vote de l'assemblée de votre
journal merci Julien merci Bruno
Retailleau